- If it's anything like pho.
This is gonna be fun.
I tried.
(giggles)
(fun music)
- I don't know what
Vietnamese street food is.
- Mm mm.
Definitely expecting a lot of spice.
- I've never eaten Vietnamese
street food before.
- And I have it a lot.
- But we've both eaten food
that's fallen on the street.
- I grew up eating
Vietnamese and Chinese food
so I've definitely had some of these.
- [Voiceover] Cheers, buddy.
- God damn!
- This isn't the fault of the food,
but there's cilantro in it,
and so it takes like garbage.
- The meat is so big in it!
- I think I'm in love.
- Not lipstick friendly, this spring roll.
- I don't even wanna like, keep eating,
'cause I just wanna have it forever.
- Hmm, hmm.
- Okay.
- This smells amazing.
- Smells so good.
- I'm excited because--
- Shrimp!
- Your parents would make it like, fresh?
And they'll bring out a
batch and it's like hot,
and you'll finish it, and they'll bring
another one and another
one and another one.
- Is the fish sauce made of fish?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Okay.
- Mmmmmm, that fish sauce, though, son!
- This is dope, this is very, very tasty.
- Are you gonna eat that onion?
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] There's pig
three ways on this plate.
- My Mom used to make this
too, like in a big bowl,
and literally, I'll just
eat it for meals and meals.
- It sounds like your whole
life growing up it was your Mom
turning out food and
you're just eating it.
- It's like Thanksgiving all the time,
like you get so much different kinds
of foods everywhere all the places.
- You realize that combining
things makes them better?
- I do know that.
That's why I'm combining
all this [bleep] in my face.
- I want it to be a little firmer.
- Ooh, no I love the softness.
- I would drink fish sauce.
Wouldn't you?
- No.
- My breath is gonna
smell like this for days.
- [Voiceover] Oooh.
- [Voiceover] What?
- Colors
- The brown black stuff is chunky.
Is it beans?
(slurping)
- Oh, God.
- The texture of the green
stuff is really weird.
- I really like it when the
desserts are also an activity
because it's just fun for the kids.
- It's crunchy, it's
chewy, it's like gooey.
- It would be really
awesome and refreshing
for a summer day.
- I love that it's like ice cream,
but not too cold to
give me a brain freeze.
- It brings me back home,
so like my family and my Mom
and I love it so much.
- Asian people always do--
- You just know what you're doing with it.
- Their food's so good.
- The fish sauce, really--
- Yeah, that was the cream of the crop.
- I wanna eat Vietnamese street food
for the rest of my life.
- We out, we did it!
Good job, sorry.